in this video you're going to learn how
to write the equation of a quadratic
which is a parabola but we're going to
be given a vertex and a point that the
graph goes through so the equation that
you're going to want to be familiar with
is this quadratic equation here in
vertex form where H and K are the vertex
or the point where that Parabola bends
and so if we're going to solve for this
equation sometimes what I like to do is
just draw a little graph just to kind of
visualize so we have a Vertex here at 2
-3 and it's going through the point 3
comma
0 and remember that parabas they're
symmetric about that vertex so if I was
to fold this over I'd have another
corresponding Point like that so there
is our Parabola right there and we want
to get an equation for it so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to start with
this uh general form the vertex form and
I'm going to plug in our vertex H and K
so it's going to look something like
this y = a * x - 2 the x coordinate of
the vertex squared Min -3 now you might
be saying Mario why is this min-2 and
this is a positive two well see how this
says x minus H another way that students
sometimes like to think about it is this
number that's grouped with the x that
has the opposite effect on the graph the
minus two is actually shifting it
positive2 to the right and this K value
the minus three has the same effect it's
shifting it down three now all we have
to do is solve for this a value and
that's why they're giving us this
additional point on the graph 3 comma 0
so this is our X and this is our y so
let's go ahead and substitute 0er in for
y 3 in for
x and then we can solve for a 3 - 2 is 1
1^ 2ar is 1 so this comes out to
a minus 3 and all we have to do is add
three to both sides of the equation to
get a by itself and a is equal to three
now we're going to take that three we're
going to put it back in for a here and
now we've got our equation of our
quadratic in vertex form if you want to
rewrite this in the standard form you
can think of this as x - 2 * another x
-2 multiply those together then multiply
by three then subtract three put it in
descending order and that'll be in your
standard form if you want to see another
example and you want to test yourself
and get some practice which I recommend
follow me over to that video right there
and we'll do some more practice I'll see
you there